bullshit
well you were right to be afraid but not
of him you see the critics ass is
actually the gateway to hell what yes
see for yourself do you mind a
remodeling this place needs up the land
why is the gateway to hell in the
critics ass
well that's the funny thing about hell
you see it could appear just about
anywhere the grocery store the
laundromat and most political
fundraisers but now I thought hell was
more a state of being the absence nave
rejection of God leading to a world
devoid of happiness compassion or love
nope it's a place in your ass haven't
you ever seen open horizon oh you mean
that piece of wait a minute isn't that
the movie with the cult following where
even the cult following doesn't know why
there's a cult following oh yes and
according to the director of MORTAL
KOMBAT hell can even exist in space
really yes my friend that sounds like
really lazy design work I'm putting in a
plan
The Horizon was one of those films that
got a lot of advertising when it came
out but was a critical and box-office
failure leading to a disappearing real
quickly but over the years it's grown a
bizarre fanbase of who you may ask
mmm remember those jocks who wanted to
think they were into hardcore scary
movies for a couple seconds
hey uh you remember that movie that was
like Star Wars but kind of scary
well then horizon yeah yeah that was a
thing okay I can't say that's all of
them but it's usually the ones that I've
come across nonetheless it's still hard
to figure out why this has gotten the
attention it has over the years but
maybe business - you mean we can figure
it up so let's see whitehill has such a
fucking weird realtor this is event
horizon so after hearing music by that
nightclub you pass by and go yeah we get
some background on our futuristic
setting Oh
so we colonize the moon this year huh
why am I always the last to know these
things Christ this is always what
happens why I ride my hoverboard too
much am seeing how this is from the
director of Mortal Kombat I expect to
see some pretty bad CGI coming up here
oh yeah mmm taste that mediocrity oh
that's making Sharkboy and Lavagirl look
like Laura the Rings right now hold on I
guess it made a great effect I can find
in here we get a pretty cool-looking
image which it turns out is just the
dream of our main character Sam Neill
and naturally what you just saw plays no
part in anything whatsoever Christ I
really hate these dream sequences and
movies that don't tie into anything
they're the equivalent of that
girlfriend who tells you all her dreams
without relating it to the situation oh
my god it's such a weird dream last
night that things were bloating and this
guy was floating and I was floating - Oh
weird oh my god
Oh Lynch's wife says that he puts her
dreams in his movies all right fine it
will get you off my back oh my god I had
a dream you and say that we then see
kneel on a space station where the
cinematography takes the flushing toilet
approach as he intercept a ship known as
the Lewis and Clark yeah they were gonna
call it the second year we have but even
in the future nobody cares about Native
Americans the captain of the ship is
played by Laurence Fishburne which
judging by his acting makes me wonder
more and more this was just a really bad
prequel to the matrix we were taken off
a well-deserved leave and sent into
Neptune space we are now three billion
klicks from the nearest outpost what if
I told you you were starring in shit now
of course it couldn't rip off the matrix
because it wasn't around yet but you
know what happen around for a while at
this time alien and tell me if you see
anything fucking anything that has the
tiniest bit of an alien feel or look
actually let me make this easier tell me
if there's anything that does not have
an obvious alien feel or look even the
truckers in space thing in alien it
worked because that's what they were
they were coming home from a mining job
and that's only they were woken up to
check out a disturbance here these
people were specifically hired to locate
an abandoned ship and yet they act like
they have no idea about anything
space-related
use a rotating magnetic field to focus a
narrow beam of gravitons decent 10-fold
space-time layman's terms
fuck layman's terms do you speak English
no sorry allow me to explain using port
piece of paper represents space-time it
folds space so the point a and point B
coexist in the same space and time hmm
tell me more about this space thing so
you can't actually do that the law of
relativity prohibits faster than light
yeah come on buddy we're mere astronauts
it's not like we're smart or anything
I built it that creates a dimensional
gateway that allows it to jump
instantaneously from one point of the
universe to another light-years away ah
well it's difficult ooh it's all math
yeah what do you think we are rocket
scientists oh wait we are we should
probably know all of this
in fact there's technically very few
scientists on the voyage at all when
enough made more sense to send more of
them in or anyone who knows what they're
fucking supposed to do skipper I got a
question yeah what the fuck are we doing
way out here
Oh perhaps the good doctor will be kind
enough to tell us we wanted to keep that
a surprise now I know you're all
qualified to handle top-secret
information but I saw one of you take a
selfie with selfies birthday cake and
well the entire surprise party was just
ruined this calls for another completely
pointless scare
I almost wanted to convince you that was
a real scream but then halfway through I
was like bucket its event horizon all
right Christ
tell me fake out dreams cut a guy hell
Oh with a horrible drink well at least
I'm awake now ah that's it I'm sticking
with reality
come on to shower chat when they finally
get to the event horizon Fishburne
navigates them in with his incredibly
silly hanging chair to the cozy club he
looks like a rocking old lady why does
he have that the other people have a ton
more buttons to push why does he get the
jungle gym furniture we I'm a spaceman
after connecting safely to this
incredibly immature music I'm now
putting over it they send in a probe to
scope out the area to make sure it's
safe for them to oh are they just going
themselves places the deep freeze oh
yeah deep freeze huh
is that why we can still hear the water
moving as it floats by maybe they
mistook it for a room-temperature freeze
so yeah seeing how Mele is the designer
of this ship
you have to wonder what the scientific
relevance is of why the fuck it looks
like Bowser's Castle no no the doors
need teeth that's very important I know
a reflective tunnel seems pointless but
scientific I swear don't ask me why
everything looks like Marilyn Manson's
auto repair it's based off that super
technologically advanced space stuff do
I have to explain with another pinup
poster sure why doesn't nobody scream
right in this movie that sounded more
like a dog barking than a woman shouting
but the dimensional black portal hole
thingy starts acting funny as one of
them takes a closer look no don't touch
it you'll be wearing emo haircuts and
doing tap dancing in bars for weeks he
gets sucked in but they pull him back
only to discover things aren't making
much sense I mean more than usual
it was liquid in the hole quartz turns
hot it would mean the Gateway was a
penis that's it yes the Gateway was open
anyway couldn't be open mr. Cooper's
delusional what he would have to believe
him there's no way he could make that up
hello what happened here doctor after
seeing a typical Arby's eater the rest
of the crew is realizing they start to
see things that should logically be
their fetus seriously did the casting
screaming lesson from Marmaduke fetus
forever sure you know I just realized
ghosts aren't very scary when they have
a little bit of attitude on them and I
don't need forever like when you
promised to rub my feet forever I mean
forever
of course as scientific astronauts they
come to one logical conclusion what are
you telling me that this ship is alive
you wanted an answer and it's the only
one I've got
Wow that was like your first answer
I mean Star Trek had like five episodes
with a hallucinating stuff and they
always had a logical conclusion for it
but you you're like boom shits alive we
gotta sacrifice a virgin I'm looking at
you Eddie remain Franco speaking of
which he wakes up from his sleep and
wanders in a daze towards the airlock to
kill himself but to be fair that might
be because everybody on the crew
apparently insists on calling him baby
bear no baby bear come on okay baby bear
is that really gonna put him in a better
mood calling him that
bag baby bear I told you I hate it when
you call me baby bear
all right we'll call you smoochy kids ah
buttercup honey woman I know
sneaky balls you will do what we called
you shrinky boss is unavoidable
you
so our junior extra knot wakes up from
his days and realizes what's going on
where am I I opened the door i conned
the inner door won't open when the
outside doors been triggered mama bear
open the door she says mama bear baby
bear how long until they all move into a
house tree in the middle of bear country
Justin just activated the door to the 30
second delay my baby bear won't leave
his pedal there any time soon he won't
be pretty but he should live as you'd
imagine a lot of hostility starts to
spread through the group Justin said
something about a dark inside me what's
that mean doctor I don't think it means
anything
I'm walking away now do not chase me hey
I really said that thinking you wouldn't
follow me I'd like some answers doctor
but even Fishburne starts to get freaked
out of what he's witnessing and now it's
time for what generic or cliche well
Fishburne say oh I feel looking for a
mother God mother or God or whatever it
be uh what if mercy we're we're doomed
yes NSA we're doing let's see we're
doing we're doing it oh god help us
Mecca what's up memorable lines like
these who needs effort they finally find
a video of what happened to the last
crew which leads to the Scooby and
Shaggy method of confronting the unknown
we're leaving
my ship your carcass lever and we'll
launch tack missiles at the event
horizon until I'm satisfied she's
vaporizing fuck this ship
okay I refer all rationale of scientific
discovery and exploring what the world
has never encountered to fuck this ship
can't leave she won't let you but Neil
quite bizarrely out of nowhere suddenly
decides he's the bad guy you just get
your gear and get back on the Lewis and
Clark doctor you'll find yourself
walking home I am huh I'm quite on Keros
tically deciding I belong here Anakin
Skywalker's turnaround has nothing on me
from here tons of things go wrong
Neil sabotages everyone he blows
astronauts into space
he pulls people on strings it all goes
to hell and yes I guess you can't take
that literally but one astronaut seems
just mildly annoyed that he's stranded
out in the middle of oblivion with a
fucking my goal why's this shit gonna
happen to me man I have plans tonight I
was gonna marathon Bob's Burgers on
Netflix but it's okay because he has a
rocket pack in order to get him back
like a boomerang I'll blow my
here I come motherfucker you know can we
just have a sign that reminds us that
this is supposed to be a scary movie
good because it was trying to look like
an episode of homeboys in outer space
and yes that was the thing don't Google
it to make things worse
sam neill has pretty much transformed
himself into a video game villain having
clawed out his eyes and revealed that
this plot is pretty much gone the same
direction as do I created the event
horizon to reach the stars she tore a
hole in our universe dimension of pure
evil
yeah it's pretty hard to take him
seriously what he looks like that he's
kind of like that haunted house
attraction you walk by and say oh gee I
know you're trying to just keep keep
hanging in there you'll scare somebody
it's one of the astronauts bruiser so
totally useless Rocket Man lands on the
window and Neil shoots at him because
like everyone in this movie he tends to
forget exactly what space does
blah blah
they didn't come across a ridiculous
blood scene that makes the shiny look
downright subtle Oh Balto nice who are
you death things get even worse when
literal ghosts from the past show up
just flash it to flashes terrorize you
save see senses Halloween specials more
scary than this oh come on I have that
punch sound effect but Neal somehow
turns himself into paper cut head and
reveals that the ship has in fact open
up the gates of hell
oops did you really think you could
destroy this shit she's been to a place
you couldn't possibly imagine I know to
help Wow this sheds much more light on
that passage describing Hell in the
Bible I always knew that you'd let that
part in as images of his friends
suffering and help lay over their
incredibly disinterested acting though
you're dotted with court I watched him
die and you are all coming with me yeah
yeah tell me about Hell in a minute I'm
checking my Instagram they have the only
thing that could possibly make talks of
eternal damnation even scarier a
fistfight
we can make it even scarier we have the
Star Trek music
so hell was surprisingly easy to beat as
fishburne stays behind with a black hole
that apparently fixes itself and the
galaxy has a little Boop are surviving
astronauts think they've made it out
okay but did
rescue team was safe here now safe I
honestly don't know is that how the
movie ends I guess oh you know there's a
difference between leaving a movie
open-ended and just throwing in an evil
shrug you could be like so movie yeah
what did you mean by that ending exactly
I'm you know still in hell or did it get
out because either way there's a lot of
plot holes that don't matter you just
didn't know how to end this so you rated
M night Shyamalan throwaway twisted yeah
okay let's wrap this up I'm not entirely
sure why this film has a following
because honestly it's a little too
boring to even warn one
everything is just paint-by-numbers in
terms of phoned in space horror however
I don't always hear people talking about
the version that we did get but rather
the version that we didn't get
apparently this movie was really edited
down and there's a rough cut somewhere
that's a lot more gory so gory that I'm
just gonna put the timecode here in case
you're squeamish because yeah this gets
pretty intense
remember those quick cuts of the people
suffering in hell there was apparently a
lot more of that in this movie like
Fattah and when you look at the detail
on those quick edits they actually are
pretty damn disturbing and don't get me
wrong if this isn't your thing it's
totally understandable I did still
probably be a dumb movie but at least it
would have gone all the way with
something because I got this is some
fucked up imagery here sadly though the
studio said it was too disturbing and
cut it out leaving us with just a lame
generic ass ghost flick have they kept
these cuts in and might have made the
movie stand out for help make it a lot
more unique it'd be kinda like taking
the gore out of the Evil Dead movies
it's just a big part of the identity
maybe putting it back in might have
solved a lot but yeah how ironic is that
that a guy who directed a pg-13 mortal
kombat had to be censored for gore in an
r-rated movie I guess this dude will
never get as hoarse portation
masterpiece so maybe it's not the film
itself but the filmic
what a man that fascinates before I look
at like I have the answer why but at
least if you find the flick as dull as I
do there's at least a more interesting
making up story that can go along with
it I guess one of those is liable to get
your attention but for me I much rather
watch what this creepy s imagery was
going to be than the snooze fest if he
came and speaking of Hell you thinking
of relocating anytime soon whoa
the smell is pretty bad even for me but
I just can't go without leaving you with
some form of suffering you put Hill up
my ass how much more suffering can you
get the Matt well I have been scouting
under William Shatner's toupee
alright I'll head out there thank God
I mean you whatever hey Tamara do you
woke up my ass to see if hell is still
there I'm gonna go be a backup singer
for brentalfloss just do it there's
nothing in there but a book whoa by
Stephen King oh
you
Peters
everybody doing the charity shout-out
this week and this is one that I have
actually worked with I've actually
volunteered for before so I can tell you
in person it is a wonderful charity
that's just a great idea - it's called
Feed My Starving Children and it does
exactly what the title says it helps
feed starving children all over the
world and the wonderful thing about is
that there's two things you can do you
can do the traditional route which is of
course donating money to help them
continue their goal and feed children
all around the world or you yourself can
actually volunteer and help them pack
the food and send them out this is
something where the more people they
have the faster it goes and it is so
disgustingly easy a kid could do it heck
kids have done it and it's something
where just an hour of your time can feed
tons and tons of kids the more people
that show up and do it the faster and
the better it goes and the more kids it
feeds and that's the most gratifying
thing in the world just knowing that a
couple seconds just dishing a spoonful
of food into a bag can help save
somebody's life it can feed a child and
no child really nobody should have to go
to bed hungry and no one should have to
go through this so this is a wonderful
organization and they're just phenomenal
people and they do a wonderful job and
it's definitely worth checking out so
please please definitely either
contribute some money and the amount
will help or if you don't have the money
just go volunteer some of your time
because it takes so little time so
little effort but it makes such a big
huge difference so please definitely go
find out some more information and see
if this is something to be interested